Hello everyone,
welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is the languages of South
Africa.
The Republic of South Africa covers much
of the southern tip of the African
continent and as a place where numerous
native African cultures as well as
former colonial populations have
converged resulting in a state of true
linguistic diversity.
South Africa has 11 official languages
that have been recognized in its
constitution since 1993.
If that seems like a lot to you,
you're probably right.
South Africa is among the countries with
the largest number of official languages
at the national level.
Number one is actually neighboring
Zimbabwe with 16 official languages,
some of which are also official in South
Africa.
These are the 11 official languages of
South Africa in order of most spoken to
least spoken as a first language,
Zulu,
Hosa,
Afrikaans,
English,
northern Sudan,
Swana,
southern Sudan,
Tsonga,
Swazi,
venda,
and in the ballet,
over 99 percent of South Africans to
speak one of these languages as a first
language.
All of these languages are members of
the southern through branch of the
Nigeria Congo language family,
with the exception of Afrikaans and
English,
which are Germanic languages,
brought to the country by Europeans.
The Dutch first arrived in what is now
South Africa in 16,
Fifty two establishing the Cape colony
in the western portion of the country.
Also living in this area were native
Koyczan people and other Africans who
spoke two languages.
The British seized control of the Cape
Colony in 18,
15 and British settlers began to arrive.
The brewers,
the descendants of the original Dutch
settlers disliked many aspects of
British rule,
but one of them was the anglicization of
the Cape Colony and the attempt to force
English on the horse as a medium of
instruction in schools.
They wanted to continue to use Dutch as
their medium of instruction and to
continue speaking.
They're distinct dialect of Dutch called
Cape Dutch,
which would later evolve into Afrikaans.
Boris began the great trek migrating
inland and creating their own bore
republics in an area more densely
populated with African tribes who spoke
two languages.
The British later took control of the
board republics and created the Union of
South Africa in 1910 that eventually led
to the creation of the Republic of South
Africa.
From that point on,
there were two official languages,
English and Dutch,
but Dutch as spoken by the boers had
evolved into a distinct language called
Afrikaans,
which replaced Dutch as an official
language in 1925.
These two colonial languages became the
prestige languages of South Africa and
Speakers of other languages.
Didn't really have any say in the
matter.
During the apartheid era,
schools were segregated not only based
on race,
but also based on mother tongue.
Native speakers of English and Afrikaans
were taught in their native language
throughout their schooling.
With second language instruction in the
other official language,
black South Africans were required to
study in their mother tongue for most of
their primary school years after which
point then normally studied in English.
But in 1974,
the apartheid government implemented a
new policy requiring instruction in
black schools to be conducted in a 50
slash 50 split between English and
Afrikaans.
With the language of instruction,
depending on the course,
this was implemented without consulting
the black population in opposition to
this move led to the Soweto uprising of
1976.
Afrikaans was seen as the language of
the oppressor.
Since the apartheid government was
dominated by white speakers of
Afrikaans,
while English was seen as a more
cosmopolitan language.
When apartheid ended in the early 19
nineties,
a new constitution was written that
added nine additional African languages
as official languages in order to be
more inclusive of the entire population.
The education system now is based on
freedom of choice with every individual
free to choose which of the 11 official
languages to be educated in for the
first part of their schooling.
As long as there's sufficient demand for
the school to provide it,
that means that they don't have to study
in their mother tongue if they don't
want to.
Let's take a look at the map of South
Africa.
When apartheid was abolished,
the four provinces of South Africa and
the homelands enclaves for African
ethnic groups were abolished and nine
new provinces were created.
This map shows the most dominant
languages in South Africa down to the
local level.
You can see that the 11 official
languages are clustered mainly in
certain areas and may predominate in
certain provinces,
but they don't correspond exactly to
provincial borders.
You can see that Afrikaans predominates
in the West while the [inaudible]
language is predominate in the east and
English predominates in South Africa's
major urban centers.
As you can see,
there's quite an intricate linguistic
situation in the eastern part of the
country,
so let's zoom in and look at the African
languages there.
As I mentioned earlier,
the Non European languages of South
Africa are mainly members of the
southern Bantu branch of the Niger Congo
language family,
and these account for about 70 percent
of the population or around 40 million
people.
These southern through languages display
some features typical of the languages
in general.
They follow an Svo word order like
almost all Bantu through languages.
They're tonal and they're are largely a
gluten active and feature a large number
of affixes to nouns and verbs.
Most Ben,
two languages do not have click sounds,
but many of these southern Bantu
language is due as a result of contact
with the Koyczan languages.
The nine main southern Bantu languages
of South Africa can be further
categorized into three smaller
subdivisions,
the in Goonie languages,
the languages and the Swat.
Ranga or someone,
God group vendor forms its own group,
so there are actually four subdivisions
including this one.
The goonie branch of the southern Bantu
tree contains four of South Africa's
official languages,
Zulu,
Olsa,
Swazi,
and the belay.
The first two are the two most spoken
languages within South Africa as a first
language with Zulu representing 23
percent of the population and wholesale
representing 16 percent of it.
The other two on the other are spoken by
only two point five percent in two point
one percent respectively.
Zulu is mainly spoken in Kwazulu,
Natal,
and most of Puma Langa where Swazi and
in the belay are spoken as well.
Wholesale is the majority language of
the Eastern Cape,
but has communities have speakers in
other provinces as well as other
official languages.
Do the Goonie languages feature?
Click consonants.
You can hear one of them in the name of
the language.
Actually,
this is the first time I've tried to
pronounce a click consonant,
so I may be pronouncing the name of the
language wrong from the point of view of
a native speaker,
but I guess it's something like that
whole song.
All of the in Goonie languages are
mutually intelligible to a large extent,
so to Twana.
The second largest of the southern Bantu
branches is the [inaudible] branch,
which has three languages within it.
Northern [inaudible] representing nine
point one percent of South Africa's
population Swana with eight percent and
southern Sudan,
or simply with seven point six percent.
Altogether.
They represent just under a quarter of
the population of South Africa,
around 13 point 6 million people.
Each of these three languages serves as
the majority language in the province
that it's most widely spoken in southern
[inaudible] in the free state,
not in the northwest province,
and there is also a significant
population of speakers in the Northern
Cape with which it shares a border and
to northern Sudan.
In Limpopo,
southern [inaudible] contains click
consonants due to contact with an Goonie
languages.
While some urban varieties of northern
sue to have in recent times been
acquiring clicks as well,
it's one that uses some click sounds,
but only in interjections and video
phones on the metal,
for example,
and like the Goonie languages,
the Twana languages are generally
mutually intelligible as well.
Tsonga or Swati Rhondda,
although there are other languages
within this branch,
the only one that has official status is
Tsonga.
Other languages of this group are
mutually intelligible and are oftentimes
considered part of the tone of the
language found in the northeast.
Most of the Tsongas speaking,
people live in Limpopo or Puma Malanga.
Some features click sounds in just a few
words.
Another interesting phonological feature
is whistled sibilant consonants.
I haven't been able to find a sample
from Tonga,
but here's a sample of a similar sound
in the [inaudible] language
vendor,
one of the less spoken of the official
languages in South Africa.
Venda comprises two point four percent
of the population or one point $3
million speakers who are almost all
concentrated on the northern border of
Limpopo near Zimbabwe where it's closest
linguistic relatives.
Live vendor has no click.
Sounds okay.
Afrikaans and English,
the two Germanic languages of South
Africa,
Afrikaans and English or the third and
fourth most spoken languages in the
country with 13,
five percent and nine point six percent
of citizens speaking them as their first
language respectively.
People outside of South Africa might
assume that native speakers of Africans
are all white,
but that's not the case.
It's the majority language in the
Northern Cape.
Then Western Cape provinces where most
of the nation's colored population or
mixed race population lives and more
than 75 percent of colored South
Africans speak Afrikaans as their first
language.
Why is that?
It's because they were part of the
language is development.
The origin of the colored community lies
in the early days of the colony.
When Dutch settlers intermarried with
indigenous Koyczan women or slaves from
Africa,
India and Southeast Asia,
but they also interacted linguistically
and by learning Dutch in perfectly as a
second language.
They influenced the direction of the
Dutch dialect that would evolve into
Afrikaans.
It's also spoken as a native language by
smaller numbers of the South Asian and
black South African populations and it's
spoken by over 60 percent of the white
population as a native language in
total.
It's the first language of about 13
point five percent of the population and
it's spoken by an even larger number as
a second language.
If you haven't seen my language profile
on Afrikaans from a couple of years ago,
you can check it out right here.
English is spoken as a native language,
mainly in the Western Cape,
how attain and Zulu natal as these are
aware of the major cities can be found.
Plus it's widely spoken as a second
language,
English as the native language of nine
point six percent of the population,
including around 36 percent of the white
population.
It's also the native language of most
Indian South Africans.
They speak with an accent distinct from
white South Africans,
speakers of English during the apartheid
era,
interaction with whites was limited,
which allowed their own distinct variety
of English to develop in isolation with
some fun,
illogical influences from Indian
languages.
I've mentioned the Koyczan languages a
few times and you may be wondering why
they aren't on the list of official
languages.
Well,
the Koyczan where the first indigenous
people have much of South Africa before
the migration of Ben to peoples and
later Europeans through conflict with
Ben too,
and Europeans Koyczan were driven into a
much smaller area and now most Koyczan
live in the Kalahari desert.
Some Koyczan intermarried with Europeans
and became part of the colored
population while others died from
conflict and disease.
The end result of all this is that only
a very small population of Koyczan
remain in South Africa and their Koyczan
languages are therefore not widely
spoken and are not official languages.
Koyczan languages do not form a single
language family and are not accepted as
being related to each other,
but all of them feature extensive use of
click consonants.
As I stated before,
the click sounds used.
[inaudible] languages come from contact
with Koyczan languages.
The most widely spoken Koyczan language
in South Africa is [inaudible] or
[inaudible] with around 50,000
speakers.
This language has an additional 250,000
speakers in neighboring Namibia.
There are other Koyczan languages in
South Africa that are severely
endangered like Greek,
well with only a few dozen speakers
remaining language in society.
In a society with such linguistic
diversity,
it's inevitable that the majority of the
population will be bilingual or
multilingual.
Most white and colored South Africans
are bilingual and English and Afrikaans
and a smaller number of speak,
one of the African languages as well,
Indian South African speak English and
usually some Afrikaans and some speak in
Indian language as well.
Typically,
older people,
many black South Africans speak three,
four,
five,
or even more languages.
It's common for them to speak their
native African language,
English and Afrikaans and one or more
other African languages.
They're often able to speak the other
languages,
have the same sub group as their native
language because they're closely related
and in many cases mutually intelligible.
You may be wondering if the languages
within each subgroup or mutually
intelligible,
why are they considered separate
languages?
Well,
what does a language versus what is a
dialect is a murky issue as always,
but I think it's partly because they
each have their own standardized variety
and it's partly because each one is
associated with a distinct ethnic group.
These days,
business and politics are emotionally
conducted in English and English as the
most common language of broadcast and
media for a long time.
English and Afrikaans had equal status
as dual lingua.
Franca is of South Africa,
but Afrikaans has been declining in that
regard.
That's partly due to the stigma attached
to off recons as it's seen as the
language of apartheid.
In addition to that,
education in South Africa tends to lean
toward English.
In typical South African schools,
the first three grades are taught in the
student's mother tongue,
but after that school work is conducted
in either Afrikaans or English.
Schools can teach in the native language
longer,
but since secondary school matriculation
exams are only conducted in English and
Afrikaans.
There's a strong motivation to switch to
one of those languages early on,
but rather than Afrikaans most choose
English due to its utility and prestige
and in many cases families will forego
students being taught in their first
language and go straight into English to
jumpstart their proficiency,
but whether this is a help or a
hindrance is a source of much debate.
The emphasis on English and Afrikaans
after the first three or four years of
initial schooling is a lasting influence
of the colonial era.
Today there are 11 official languages
and in theory and in law they are equal,
but in practice,
English and Afrikaans are still the most
influential languages at the national
level,
and this is still the case for now,
despite the fact that Africans has lost
some of its prestige.
The question of the date for South
Africans,
which languages do you speak and in what
situations do you use them and for other
people,
how many official languages are there in
your country?
Do you think that system works well for
Be sure to follow lane,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and Instagram,
and once again,
thank you to all of my wonderful patrion
supporters,
especially these ones on the screen who
are my top tier patrion supporters.
Many thanks to them as always and to
everyone.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.